today's episode is is one of the
funniest men maybe in the planet and
maybe even on other planets we don't
really know what he's doing with his
spare time you know it he's the one of
the wonderful hosts of your mom's house
podcasts he's he's a conspirator he's a
comedian and he's a he's a confidante I
think give it up for our guest today on
this past weekend is mr. Tom Segura
[Music]
little bit I was too bad
logo somebody I know did that really do
you start to get amazed it like the the
level of fan like you know it's
interaction you get from your listeners
that's like unbelievable
and then sometimes a real [ __ ]
all-star will send you something where
you're like holy [ __ ] like song we have
a lot of song submissions yeah so the
people sometimes [ __ ] around on like
what's the call like sound SoundCloud
yep no the the at the Apple one you
don't talking about you can't think of
the name but anyways you GarageBand and
you could tell that it's like you know
they just loop some once okay it's like
but sometimes I got music composer will
make something and you're like Jesus
Christ this is like a you know a real
song that you may know yeah that's what
I do like choppin or like a Mozart or
something somebody's like wow yeah it's
impressive an artist - I'm most
impressed with the artists and I think a
lot of like the the Photoshop people are
oh yes that comedy content collective is
like a group of them together dude
so funny they make you know memes videos
oh yeah they're so funny hat goes to one
guy yeah sent us a bunch of hats um you
know so sometimes they make you know
they'll make [ __ ] for us some guys made
me children's clothes well I've gotten
some strange stuff sin in you know neat
things some things are great like you
know we got a guy that sends these these
candles that's great um yeah and
sometimes it gets a little wild like
somebody chiseled something into some
deer feces or something like in a
certain place and brought it oh we got
some poop some dried poop yeah I don't
like well I mean so nice when people
bring you things but when you're on the
road and they're like I have this for
you it's a six by four foot bat carved
with your net and like yeah I got fly oh
man yeah and they're like yeah they
don't think Apple I'm like I can't bring
this if I don't like it I'll take it
because I'm not
I'm gonna bring it right if I really
like I'm like will you please ship this
to me dude
yeah because I'd like to have this oh
that's nice oh that's a good that's a
good way to think to do it but ship ship
the thing if you're if it's a big right
like a yeah oh yeah if it's real big
some yeah I'm trying to think of
interesting things it's definitely some
heavy stuff that's been the craziest
thing yeah some guy did a bronze bust he
said it was of me didn't look kind of
like a black me Cana mm-hmm which is
fine yeah sure and it's uh but I wasn't
ready I would go Latino before I go
black that's me personally but I was you
are parlor to you know right but I go
full talking about having a pistol being
on a [ __ ] animals back you know I can
drinking aloe vera do ya [ __ ] wagons
okay okay okay for life but yeah yeah
yeah me not a mucho what yeah I was told
you speak Spanish I'll speak enough to
survive and probably I speak enough to
work in a kitchen I got you but but I'm
practice a little salad and you're like
yeah okay yeah more like yeah poor low
style more more salt yeah yeah yeah
teacher honest a did ya see way yeah and
a violencia too but but I would love to
do a tour like in spanish-speaking
countries if I'm able to get my Spanish
good and well enough would you let me go
on tour with you in a spanish-speaking
country I'm trying to organize and yet
the answer is yes and I'm trying to
organize it for sometime 2020 do like a
few shows yeah wow I need a couple more
years then so I'm talking maybe I'll do
it then too but I mean yeah three but
like I did a Spanish show here in LA
mm-hmm and and I tell you I haven't been
that nervous since like 10th like ten
years ago
you know I mean because I was like yeah
and I was like I wrote stuff out I said
you know write [ __ ] out now you just
kind of go up you know little notes but
I was typing stuff out rehearsing and I
was like and I even had a part where I
really stumbled you know but the
advantage is this the advantage is like
I was on on a Spanish speaking show and
everybody is a
native Latin person so then they're like
oh this Americans coming up so then you
actually buy yourself favor because
they're like you're not supposed to be
able I say to do it you know so I think
that helped me with the crowd is they're
like this [ __ ] I could see that white
boys gonna do it I know and then you
start once you start and you hit a
couple jokes they're like hey it's great
you know it's like I don't know was it
was it did you feel as masterful or and
not to say that you're a master but I
mean you're too obviously you're very
good at your craft you've worked really
hard
do you did you feel as a like a
proficient yes no of course not
no as scary which is like but that's
kind of the exciting part yeah cuz I was
like I kind of knew how I was gonna
start but then you know in English if
you stumble it's just something about
your own length you can recover make fun
of yours like and if you're not my
Spanish used to be like I would say 9
out of 10 almost 10 out of 10 right but
I mean like oh that's better than a lot
of Mexican people I've met here in LA no
second generation no yeah totally but I
mean when I when I went to school yeah
like in Spain and like I'm going to
classes and writing term papers you get
I was dreaming in Spanish you get like
really proficient duermo huh yeah
exactly swear though good luck okay that
luck sweat day is like yeah oh yeah
that's when you sueño yeah yeah yeah but
I mean when I came back from that I was
on I was on the most proficient level I
could possibly be at now I would say you
know maybe it may be on a good day it's
a 7 out of 10 because it just diminishes
if you don't use it yeah so that's
that's the tricky part is like
practicing it to a point where you feel
like I mean I'm good if I go do it I'm
gonna be the American doing the show
there yes right so they're already gonna
be excited that you're even trying
exactly I think that that's that's a big
event and if you were to do it's the
same thing they'd be like an American
person's coming here to do this so
whatever level you're at they're gonna
be like you know now even if you were
like kind of not great at it I think it
would even be even Valerius yeah Wow
yeah that's so
yeah that would be so tough to think
like okay now I'm just gonna go what if
you get halfway through a sentence and
you're conjugations back it happened on
that show I did yeah they kind of
forgive like they get you're trying to
do it yeah because we've all seen
foreigners do English stand-up right I
mean at the store you've seen yeah and
you're so supportive you're like oh wow
they do this and then if they [ __ ] up a
sense it's funny because you're watching
a comedy show oh yeah like he's saying
it wrong actually becomes part of the
joke yeah yeah yeah people love that
yeah yeah I would love to be I think I
think I would love to be Mexican I don't
if I would love if you love to be
Mexican yeah what do you mean it just
seems like like not like incarceration
you know what I'm saying I'm not trying
to go deep deep no no I'm trying to go
like kind of safe safe Mexican you know
safe Mexican yeah which is like kind of
I would say kind of near where the
Dodgers play I guess somewhere you know
Park yeah yeah yeah but yet level yeah
but Echo Park like in the actual like in
a or Elysian Park right isn't that where
they end up playing that they're the
police yeah yeah I don't know it's near
Echo Park though the lesion yeah um but
yeah I would love that I think some like
I would do I would go black it's too
dangerous I think still for me to be
black yeah yeah you mean if the option
was there I gotta be black in Seattle
right that's easy bro I know what I'm
saying like it that's yeah that's
[ __ ] for sure but like Houston yeah
has be riskier yeah then you get to like
Biloxi or something oh yeah no you get
to Gary Indiana and then it's do you
remember being a kid and being like oh
my god I wish I was black like when you
cuz when you're a kid you know first
you'd have no idea that Pete like I
remember my first best friend we're
talking like five years old
yeah and it was black but I didn't make
the distinction that there's really dick
you know I mean like you don't right
point it out and then like you turn I
don't know maybe it's like eight or
something and you start having interests
like music sports and you're like oh we
[ __ ] suck yeah like I'm watching
football and I'm like how come nobody
that I like looks like me yeah you know
nobody like it was Jerry Rice yeah and
Deion Sanders I'm like who that where's
my gun they're like this is uses the
basket yes yeah Michael Jordan like no
one's us
yeah who's us oh this is always a guy
like standing there like this you know
like guys are a guy that they mock yeah
and make a [ __ ] fool of cross up when
he's like oh yeah and you're like that's
Mike that's like that's who you are
you're that guy or like football I
remember watching college football it's
like you know you watch all the good
games like ACC SEC get and then then
they're like you know we've seen the BYU
they're having a good year bunch of
white guys like it's all slow and [ __ ]
yeah like there's no [ __ ] high
seating on the TV like what's going on
there's no punt returns
yeah just like sensible blocking like
four yard average runs like this [ __ ]
sucks some of the players even have
whistles you're like this this seems
your own yes
yeah there's no and I remember being
like that's what I want to be I want to
be black yeah I remember thinking let me
think about that it's so interesting man
III mean I think that I sometimes I feel
like that black culture doesn't realize
how how much a lot of white people want
to be black well yeah but that what gets
twisted up in that too is that and I can
and there's a good point to it I think
right is that we'll say or you'll see
you know why people feel I wish I was
black and they're like you wish you were
the most right the coolest parts of
being black right right but like you're
skipping over all the [ __ ] that we
deal which is totally legit right right
they're like you don't deal with like
being profiled or followed to restore
being like are you buying something like
that all the [ __ ] right the
institutional racism is just kind of
built into society yeah they're like do
you want to deal with that part and
you're like well no I just but like not
as much the [ __ ] dunkings looks cool
yeah it's cool okay that's really you're
never alone kind of like if you go into
a store no one gives a [ __ ] if I'm in
there yeah you want to be profiled
well I want to be cared about it's like
one of the reasons I think I kind of
like surgery and stuff because we like
what then I like surgery like surgery
yeah are like surgical procedures you
know do you like watch them I mean I've
watched someone the internet but I watch
I like going and being a part of it you
like being present at a surgery yeah on
my cellphone yeah you're a [ __ ] or on
yourself yeah I like well first one not
gonna do my own surgeries you know no
you shouldn't yeah
people have oh dude I got enough with
this girl one time I let her try to cut
something out of my hip and she said she
could do like surgery small I could take
your appendix out basic [ __ ] yeah of
course she was anyone that agreed so did
she cut you oh yeah yeah really cut into
this thing on my hip yeah it's now it's
actually scarred up pretty bad I'll show
you it just you tell crazy but now it's
got me oh [ __ ]
but it looks like a cyst is it oh I
don't know you're not gonna ask a real
doctor I've had enough of medical
profession have you ever I went and
watched 13 surgeries in a day once oh my
god so I was like 14 years old and we
had this science project and they were
like what do you want it to be and I was
like like ever rich but I was like no I
I go I want to be a doctor so I was a
freshman in high school I had no idea
obviously what it takes to be a doctor
okay you were tall probably I was I was
like a doctor actually tall aptitude I
was like I was only like an inch or two
shorter than I am now and like 40 pounds
less when I went to the doctor like to
the hospital to what they were like
which medical school are you in I was
like I'm a freshman in high school
so anyways they set it up and they're
like this kid once they all thought that
he must be like really smart if you
wanna be a doctor I was a [ __ ] the
2.0 yeah I just thought like it sounded
cool so then they they go in and they
take me to surgery start it like 6:00
a.m. through the afternoon
and I am like almost puking in
somebody's thinks they're like we're
gonna remove a cyst from this lady's
vagina she don't say anything
cuz she's awake she's only like below
the waist we've you know and it's so
they go in there they're like all this
like a record-sized cyst come take a
look at this and they poked it it's like
shooting possum it was this Operation
Desert Storm do this is like the
weirdest place you went to the Mayo
Clinic in Jacksonville so this is like
one of the prestigious hospitals in the
country
that's her at the end of the day I was
like I don't want to be a surgeon I
don't want to be a doctor it was it was
rough man having in the stomach for all
that [ __ ] is like [ __ ] I mean I don't I
definitely don't have it yeah yeah I
mean I don't pass out and [ __ ] like that
but when you see a 85 year old [ __ ]
expand it and I was from in optioning
puss you're not like I'm ready what's
what's next it really takes you down
let's say I love that the doctor pulled
me aside he's like don't make any
comments I was like like what he gives
you like a Sigma Chi handshake yeah
trying to think of any good like jobs
that I went to be a part of we used to
do um I spent most of my life working at
pizza parlors you know what did you
really oh yeah like making delivering
all that yeah top to bottom I worked
yeah I worked top to bottom in the
industry I worked at one out here you
did yeah in the valley on Riverside
Drive somewhere oh yeah and yeah it was
just like you know to get some extra
money and I remember one day like we had
this whole system right like they get
your pizza then I walk down the thing
and then ring them up and then one day
this lady we've been doing this for a
month she's like do you not like wash
your hands between getting the pizza and
exchanging cash I was like nah she's
like does your boss tell you to I was
like nope
this is a you get whatever is on my head
I want that cash touch on my feets it's
pizza I want a little of that voodoo in
it how did you start in the pie my whole
family had worked there a lot of people
in my family had worked there that's
pizza place yeah it'd been kind of a
little bit of I guess a generational
kind of spot and uh and this place is
called BJ's pizza before this you know
now they have that BJ's Pizza house that
fancy wants to change everywhere yeah
yeah yeah this was just a freelance BJ's
you know and a lot of people that worked
there were alcoholics and if you're
running a pizza parlor it's you know
yeah that's strange
yeah to have some Darryl ex-mo
popular item oh yeah yeah dude we had
this one guy and he was always doing
methamphetamines and all that you know
he was on uppers and [ __ ] side
splitters he was on all of it yeah he
would show you just a big you know like
a open wound he had and [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] up and he um but he could make
pizza so fast you know cuz he was on
Huck was a good pizza I'm never gonna
wear it in the middle to me it was wet
in the middle yeah
the crust was a little wet in the middle
that outside yeah was pretty good yeah
thin crust right yeah it gots it
definitely got that in the middle where
it was wet on the outside yeah pretty
strong
do you like thin crust oh yeah I can't
handle all the crust as an adult I know
or a deep dish and like I want to just
give me a loaf of bread when I eat a
loaf of bread in front of you
that's Brendan Schaub was like really
the deep dish hunter is he you know
there's a Crocodile Hunter if he were if
he would be the deep dish hundred yeah
when he goes deep on eating it's wild
big [ __ ] guy like that I bet he can
really go deep
cuz imagine in his hand a piece of pizza
doesn't even like it's like yeah yeah
peanut yeah it's like uh
lancing are people would say you know
yeah on that do the hand yeah crazy huge
yeah cuz he will sometimes text at night
and be like hey you know are you how are
you doing Fitness wise and [ __ ] on
my just cuts yeah and I'm like that's
when I know he's kind of spiraling oh
right now he's like am i doing enough
yeah is my partner out working me right
now let me make sure that other people
are suffering right now yeah yeah so I
can feel okay yeah that's so funny those
guys all think like that too
Joe's like that if you do something I've
brought I swear to god one time I
brought up two jobs like it's like three
years ago now more maybe like four I was
like yes our YouTube in some like
grilling videos you know like these like
grill master guys oh yeah I was like
yeah so I got this grill and he was like
oh really and like we had this
conversation but a couple months later
he's like oh I got like meat
thermometers I'm like and then like he's
posting now he's like a grill master I
swear to god it was me saying like
guarding it I'm gonna start grilling
stuff and like
learning more about it he was like
that's interesting became a grill master
yeah yeah anytime any like super
competitive do you say it's like D'Elia
does that yeah Taliah does that I don't
gotta uh yeah what was that doing I had
one like us the snow cone thing or
something in a couple weeks later he's
[ __ ] he texts to me about him about
[ __ ] snow cones and dry ice and that
kind of she's like I bought of [ __ ] yeah
for my house I got this big I don't know
somebody gave it to me yeah - anyone
admit he bought it oh right right right
that's that's a big thing that's his
thing - yeah just it dropped from the
sky you know have you seen Dumbo drop
he's like you know just big there's a
snow cone machine just somebody gave ya
forget who that was a guy yeah okay yes
sure what else man dude Theo gate was
pretty wild huh
you know what he can't even more of a
excited about it you did I gotta know
what kept me more excited about it oh it
was me
yes really yeah and it was good cuz i a
lot of times need to feed off of other
people's excitement sometimes it bull
excitement is contagious
yeah he's a good point it is like 1/8 I
mean you ever like watch a sport an
event that you don't care about but you
realize everyone's so excited you're
like I guess I'll watch this oh yeah I
mean I feel like that like during like
the World Cup or something you know I'll
talk about this but seems like half the
world does going on yet some guys that
face painted like with house paint yeah
that's not gonna be that's gonna be a
while yeah no Thea gate was fun we
actually have this great we've been
working on it for a while behind the
scenes mm-hmm piece of like
conversations with the text messages and
like piece by piece so it'll be like a I
don't know if it'll be a ten-minute like
in-depth look at the whole thing I like
this it's fun it's fun to do yeah yeah
so do you like have you found that you
know obviously podcasting is created
like oh it creates like a world where
you kind of have to become like more
like a producer and like a creator yeah
yeah did you ever think that you were
that kind of person really or has some
of that kind of amazed you as you've
like kind of walked into different now
put on different hats but but kind of
really like like I'm I've always just
been kind of like a you know
I think just like a confusing or can
just kind of a trouble kind of comedian
kind of guy and then now it's I got more
responsibilities stuff yeah no I think
so I think I've always wanted to to do
more and it's like having having like
the platform and the like the resources
and the staff to actually try and do
these things like it's it's more fun I
like it more I feel I feel like it's
another creative outlet just like
sometimes you know like I love doing
stand-up it's the most fun but sometimes
you're like I want to do something
creative that's not exactly that one
thing and I think that podcasting and
like doing these videos and yeah as part
of that yeah I mean like even like I
told you we did that we did a document
oh yeah about this guy with the head huh
yeah that guy's a pervert huh yeah yeah
he's really perverted so I sent one of
our guys to New York to interview him
and they put together like this half
hour interview slash documentary on him
Wow but like that was that was really
rewarding to me yeah because like I like
the story I like the story of like we
played a video that was sent in from the
internet and then you know two years
later we found out that there's a real
like we never imagined that dude was
around yeah and then we found his
profile we contact him we have him on
the phone on the podcast and then we
send someone to his house I like the
whole the whole word now it's like
alright now this person is like yeah
there's like interest it shows that
there can be interest in almost anyone's
story in a way if it's absolutely if
somebody else it's like if somebody else
cares and other people will care even
just like you're saying like watching
the sport kind of definitely man
absolutely everybody has the story
this guy now has like thousand thousands
of Instagram followers and yet he's
still he's still running his his main
message which is like he wants people to
come over and [ __ ] him yeah he's like a
lot more open kind of but an of age like
Gerry Epstein or whatever that guy's
name is yeah the [ __ ] Jewish kids
dick or whatever yeah that guy that
guy's a real monster the difference is
that this is a guy who likes grown men
yeah oh yeah and he's willing just to
let you live with him if you will [ __ ]
it's crazy I know the best part is that
so they interview him and then at the
end Josh comes with he has a bag and so
we got we have like merch for him like
we made this shirt and this shirt and
he's getting the shirts like handed to
him he's rolling his eye he's like that
looks cool
he's like rolling his eyes which i think
is hilarious and he's like thanks then
Josh said we bought you a laptop he's
like oh he takes the laptop and he gives
him an iPhone and he's like he's like
can you set this up [ __ ] set up your
phone and then finally that gives him
cash and he's like thank you and he's
great but like the whole thing's
fascinating you know yeah it's a random
dude who has a story yeah I like it yeah
you know that is interesting it makes me
well first I'm gonna tell you about this
kid Jason - who I made pizzas about so
don't forget yeah yeah um so he was on
uppers right and so I couldn't even
afford up resistent back when you had
545 an hour you know for 75 they would
put a different post or something on the
the guy will put a poster that was from
a decade earlier for the minimum wage on
it and you [ __ ] forget by the way
don't forget this but nothing pissed me
off more than when I was in college and
like our suite mates like guys who lived
across the hall oh yeah would order
pizza and like not tip the driver and
even weird poor college student so I was
like dude you don't get these like I'd
tell him to keep the change but the
change is like 28 cents yeah like what
do you tip I'm like give him a couple
bucks man and they were like the people
fixated on no tip for the pizza guy I
thought it was just the most garbage
thing you could do yeah yeah it's crazy
that yeah that's crazy that uh that
people don't tip I would rather tip
sometimes more than the meal even I do
that now that I can afford it even
especially it's like that's the person
I'll always give money to especially
like when you order like out on the road
you know I'm always like have looking
for a breakfast place oh yeah go there
yeah not excite loved breakfast so it's
like I'll get I'll let him breakfast -
I'm lit coffee you know a brother and
the total is like 11 bucks yeah so what
am I gonna be like well me calculate you
dollar 60 come on no no dude you [ __ ]
yeah is nine bucks brother yeah of
course well this guy was on uppers dude
I would barely have my pizza made right
my dough out and he would have his [ __ ]
folded into a [ __ ] like a macho
malloc and a swan
you know like he would have his folded
in like a like a Sherman tank and I'd be
like he could just he was so fast with
the dough but he would see through the
the matrix with oh yeah he was just the
uppers would even help him oh he was a
dude if he was alive now and they had
Instagram and he also might be alive
yeah but if he if if there was a way to
know if he was alive or not yeah at a
mass scale mm-hmm he would be a star man
because this guy could I mean he would
have a cooking show or something
do you like the cooking shows I don't
watch any of that yeah that's more for
women I think okay watch somebody
[ __ ] cook woman lay in there her
hungry brother what is this Guantanamo
Bay yeah my still it just seems
outlandish prom night okay ladies here
I'm gonna watch somebody putting a
recipe together do you wanna see like
some high-level chef do some [ __ ] you
don't like that no I don't watch but I
think no no I just feel like but I I
love chefs but I I I always have that
thing I get overwhelmed at choices oh
wow it's a lot of times I come on like I
get a pull up Netflix you know and I'll
be like that looks [ __ ] cool and it
will be like a chef's show and I'll see
like the trailer but then I'm like yeah
I got to see what else though and I end
up always going to what almost feels
natural
you know like a crime thriller oh yeah
no then I'll be like that's just what I
want to watch yeah yeah I go into this
crime thrillers a lot um
what we talking about that was I was so
Billy comfort to remember you talked
about him rip Billy conforto right yes
he died in the embankment yeah so he was
a buddy of mine when I was young you
know he was uh you know I told you a
little bit he was a busboy basically the
pride of what is it Lucerne uh from
Laplace as a plus yeah he was a fighter
he's one of America's first homosexual
fire not fire fighters Fist fighters
what yeah so he could beat anybody's ass
do it and we know you as a fight in the
in the he was a professional fighter
he was semi-pro I think like he beat
people up like in the area you're saying
he was the first homosexual fist fighter
by far the name one really
yeah not even openly gay dude who beat
somebody's ass brah
no there's probably not I mean he would
give you the shirt off of his back I
mean losing no joke the nicest person
ever met him when like they would see
him five people though oh yeah
he'd go to clubs and people would start
[ __ ] anyway just beat the [ __ ] were you
in a lot of fights no I was in a lot of
fights I got beat up by some black guys
a couple times but I wasn't in like on a
regular or like circuit or anything yeah
and he would but he could fistfight dude
and he sold weed and he was just my
buddy kind of like took me under his
wing you know yeah and I thought one
time he gave me a couple sohma's and
tried to make a move only one I remember
and I was pretty much on conscious but
it could have happened something could
have it could have happened but when I
asked my inner spirit did it happen it
says no it says no but here's the crazy
thing is so now like we got t-shirts and
stuff made of him so I'm a surprise his
mother I'm really met his mother what
are you gonna do I'm gonna just you know
we're gonna take proceeds from the
shirts and just go do something nice for
right that's nice
so I'm gonna sit down with Ronan like
you realize how many people care about
your son yeah how about him how long ago
did he die probably 16 years ago
probably and it was it there it was yeah
in New Orleans her in Laplace he does
his whole family got pilled up and just
straight-up drove in the [ __ ] like they
were you know my whole family's from
Louisiana right yeah yep really mm-hmm
well then why don't you want to do the
wall and everything it's funny yeah it
is pretty funny I guess
yeah it's funnier now now that what that
I have even more jokes about it I really
go in yeah no but uh yeah they're all
they like the the joke starts with a
real conversation like the the bit that
I do about a conversational guy from
Lafayette and asked me like are you from
down there and I'm like the [ __ ] out
here like I you know in the joke I'm
like no but the truth is yeah there we
are
yeah Wow we have our whole lineage
traced back like like 1730
so that's it when we started down there
yeah so we like we found the dude the
actual think that the people who we
actually have genealogists do it damn it
was like
and nineteen years ago yeah they hired
these guys so this was like before
23andme and all that [ __ ] was like a
dude had to actually look it up yeah and
he did a presentation at a family
reunion oh yes
and it was like so 17 you know
30-something student am Francisco Segura
comes to like Spanish Liberia and
everybody's like oh this is closed down
by Lafayette it sounds like yeah and
he's like we're like oh this is cool and
they're like and he killed this guy and
that guy was like all right sounds
really cool man
and they're like and he started this
business and when I got school he's
really successful like that's
interesting like and then he left his 40
slaves to this person or Wow getting a
little hot the one mixed but mainly one
mixed kid ever family yeah the mix baby
stop shaking rattle yeah but they're all
from there yeah Wow while dude's you're
kind of a Louisiana comedian Louisiana
and Mississippi a lot of in down in
Mississippi damn dude and then
Louisville a lot of people move oh yeah
it just keeps getting Wilder ya know
southern people yeah man so you're
really that's where you're from I mean
you know laser more Midwestern but yeah
yeah we're from down there and you yeah
we did Gary Owen and you're out of
Cincinnati yeah I've never met him you
haven't never met Gary no he doesn't
seem like the kind of guy really that
probably likes to meet a lot of other
people either really I don't think so
that's the vibe you got like it doesn't
seem like he's gonna stop over to say
hey yeah it's kind of like come to him
and say hey what was it like it was it
was cool I mean I'm not a fan of Gary he
just he definitely seemed a little bit
more like come say hey to made then I'm
gonna come say hey to you I mean that's
fair enough I guess but it's fair he's
been doing it a long time yeah you know
it was very well yeah really locked down
a lane to one of a kind yeah I mean he's
yeah he's like kind of like the athletic
bill burr you know is it is he like
super athletic like he dresses like he
is so I bet he probably is lots of
Jordans and sweatpants and [ __ ] yeah
orange has a couple like white towels
hanging off from it all time yeah
really leaning in yeah
yes yeah he's definitely uh you know
he's sort of that uh yeah he's got that
he's kind of that dark ginger fire
mm-hmm mm-hmm I feel weird about
claiming places because I move so much
yeah so you know I mean like I left
since Annie when I was nine so it is my
hometown
yeah a place but I left I was not you
don't really feel like an attachment to
a place yeah not at 9:00 especially
those years after years like nine to
eighteen those are really your something
yeah I get attached to and even in those
I moved so it's like you know yeah I
feel like when you whenever you met on
whenever you met your wife did you know
that of that like oh this is gonna be my
wife or did was it no no we were if we
were we were both like new comics right
and we we got a question right here very
related well taken this is actually Gary
Ellen
he doesn't seem as athletic as ha I'm a
huge fan Brandon Paris from Georgia here
by the way Devon do you guys never come
to Georgia for the love of God at least
go to Atlanta is a big place people I've
been there so there's tons of fans here
anyways my question is just got of a
long-term relationship we were married
thought she was the one apparently not
Tom when you when you met Kristina I
know you knew I think for quite awhile
before you actually married her how did
you know she was actually the one that
way I don't make the same mistake even
though my last relationship I wouldn't
say a mistake it happened mmm how he
calls them relate his marriage a
relationship that wasn't a relationship
that didn't work out my wife I'm in a
relationship with this house and this
lady in this cat in these future plans
how do you not know um I don't know man
I mean like well people make a wrong
decision a lot of the times now but
ultimately you still just trust your gut
on everything right it's a feeling it's
like a feeling I mean yeah but I think
some people's guts are less calculate
well you're not callate definitely right
did you know they like did you well you
said you were friends for a while so I
was friends for a while
but did you have a sexual interest why
you guys were friends well I thought she
was attractive obviously but I wasn't
like I knew she was dating somebody
oh oh yeah I mean I don't let go like
I'm gonna try to pursue someone in a
relationship yeah you know I mean so we
would just see each other at shows it
was always just like I liked her
friendly cool but I mean I mean I didn't
go like hopefully you break up soon
right it's not like even a voodoo dolls
or any of that Wiccans I got a phone
call from a friend of mine who was like
she broke up with her boyfriend so I
just swooped in a friend years who you
paid to sit outside of her apartment
yeah basically yeah so yeah do I want to
live man so those guys yeah brilliant
got an idea yeah they got your back man
so he told me what was that come on come
on over now player so ya swooped in I
remember you know she had more attitude
like she was like had you know when
someone's like sometimes broken up they
got kind of a [ __ ] at it yeah I really
like that oh yeah they're like a bad
attitude you know not like permanently
but I I don't like like hey whatever you
want to do it like [ __ ] like that
immediately like I'm not so you know you
got you got you gotta follow your dick
in in all of those decisions like so
whatever excites you you have to at
least pursue hmm and then you see where
it goes and then you know you're in a
relationship I mean I struggle with a
lot of that yeah so it's interesting
that you in a relationship now
no I date but that's about it I met I
ran into you with a girl thought it was
a while ago remember we went at that
taping at the calm no no no Vegas oh
yeah yeah that was a girl that I was
dating you're hiding her yeah
and so she and I still kind of date you
know but it's like my biggest thing just
commitment issues you know I just don't
want it just really scares you I don't
know if I can live with somebody like
those scares me at a level that like
what scares you about it just right now
you've been saying it makes me feel
uncomfortable I don't know dude if I
knew man I would know you know yeah so I
don't know you do you have any interest
in having kids yeah I think I do
you do that's the part that kind of
keeps me inching over yeah cuz I lied I
think people who say you know like
because some people legit aamir like and
everyone I have kids I think makes it
makes a lot of sense to stay not
necessarily single but like what you
know why
I feel like a marriage should be like if
you want a family yeah personally
obviously do people do ever they want
but I don't know why you would get
married necessarily if you don't want a
family yeah kinda I'm a that's my
thought yeah no I mean you're just like
no I just I mean I guess if you're like
I have to legally lock this down right
then you can but I think I think family
if there's land issues or something like
that sure yeah you want the deed yeah I
signed but other than that I mean I
don't know I I feel like this dude has
to it's hard it's it's you know if you
like you know you said some people don't
make that right choice
I think people end up knowing when they
are that person and if you are the
person who doesn't have good instincts
you have to learn to not trust your
instincts we're allowed to do right
which is still also learning your
instincts so it's not only having these
things but learning them yeah yeah what
it's so do you you feel like you'll be a
lifelong bachelor type for now I don't
know I don't see one of my biggest fears
honestly is getting married or something
and then but knowing them as part of my
brain that I might get out of that and
so like then why even get into it in the
first place that's that's smart
to not act on it then like if you're
thinking like that yeah and also might
just mean that you're not just ready
you're just not ready for right now yeah
I think I might um maybe this not really
well maybe like three years from now
you'll be like oh my god I definitely
have to get married to have a kid
yeah I could I could imagine like that
that that kind of changes in you and it
might just be the person you mean that's
the thing is like I still think it's a
feeling you might need a woman who
completely transforms your thought on
that and the idea of her getting away
just completely cripples you and if
that's the case you're probably gonna be
like okay let's get married yeah I mean
because you're just so crazy about it
but you were asking me [ __ ] like do you
guys sleep in the same room yeah what
yeah could see that would be another
thing if I was here when your dad my mom
were together alive right did they sleep
in the same room no they didn't sleep in
the same really yeah my dad's up on the
couch mom slept in her room so maybe I
could be why part of that Tim is
definitely why I say yeah but yeah just
if you sucked on the couch it was
comfortable to him yeah I think so okay
he was out there you know like he didn't
act
[ __ ] I'm out here you know I think he
kind of liked it I wouldn't want to
sleep in the same bed as my mom you know
why I just wouldn't want to I don't
think like I wouldn't mind it for a nap
or something but I'm not staying in
there all night and you don't think a
man that's married to her would want to
know because but it's something about
your mom I think yeah she's just not the
kind of lady I would even play that into
it next door that long with my eyes
closed and [ __ ] think everything is
in a [ __ ] month oh really
yeah I could see her crazy temper no
just kind of like you know making a
choice in the middle of the night that
you wake up and feel like oh this is
something maybe you should have
consulted with me on even really yes
she's just kind of like a go get it kind
of lady are you close yeah we're pretty
close these days I think about as close
as we can be talking a lot yeah we talk
about sometimes it's more like listening
you know it's like yeah you ever notice
that with your parents at all yeah
sometimes I do not want to answer the
phone sometimes but I just do it just
because like I know I have like a
responsibility as a son like you know
she's probably lonelier than I am you
know she doesn't have you know that kind
of stuff my dad too will be like just
like yeah and then this and that and
he's like all right well I love you I'm
like do I get to say anything like
something back okay I was I wasn't ready
Oh what he's like what do you what is it
like I just thought a conversation would
be like more back and forth he's like
okay and then I'm like so yeah I mean
your kit your grandkids are good and
then I'm like all right man he's like
art buddy I'm like just you know that's
Carrie it's like two down like they just
want to get something out I think do you
think sometimes there is definitely a
moment I noticed I can find
conversations where where I get like
nert like yeah at the end of the
conversation like I don't know what to
say or it's like if somebody's gonna say
I care I don't care I love your oh right
you and oh yeah but that depends on who
you're talking to
right yeah but it's weird like your
brains kind of playing this mental kind
of hockey almost like air hockey it's
like it's like what do we get what do we
do right here the weirdest one and came
down is I have a friend Roman who will
like he'll be like all right so you
won't have dinner yeah be good what time
I think seven when do I meet at 7:00 he
goes yeah hangs up ho-ho
doesn't do any type of there's the you
know I mean like it like you'd be like
all right so I'll see you then all right
bye like there's no ending he just goes
so sevens good click Wow and you're like
oh did something happen yeah I'm like is
he an is yeah all right wait are you is
that how you end phone calls yeah like
what what made you not say bye he's like
I don't know we agreed on 7 like yeah
but I mean that is a bold move to just
be like it's like Marty McFly kind of
[ __ ] right
like I mean isn't that strange maybe
I'll be there yeah do you end [ __ ] you
don't end phone calls like no not like
that some people will even do texts like
that how does 7:00 sound and you'll say
good and then they don't rip right back
right it's no you got to confirm yes
yeah yeah yeah that if you're agreeing
on the time alright see you then yes
yeah that's that's enough yeah I got a
phone call to be like I'll see you at
7:00
that's crazy that's right great I mean
that's like a general telling what to do
okay yeah man that's so brave it's like
yeah it's almost like part of Call of
Duty or something yeah
oh what's that at your door I wonder if
it's a Eclair or a sugar treat could be
some steak meal or something wonderful
that you want it's been a long day you
know maybe your boss he got upset at
work and threw away your videogames or
throughout your foot lotion well you can
change that you can change your vibe and
you don't have to cook for yourself
today this morning tonight because
restaurants come to you with door - door
- connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city via your phone
the ordering is it's simple you use the
door - app and choose what you want to
eat you want to eat this you want to eat
that eat this or that and a Dasher will
bring it to you anywhere you are you've
all heard a - or one of the famous
reindeer well this is similar but
different not only is that burger place
that you love on door - already but over
three hundred and ten thousand other
amazing restaurants are as well it
connects you with door to door delivery
in over 3300 cities cities all 50 states
and
Canada our strong white friend of the
north order from your local go to Zoar
choose from your favorite chains like
Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a you want it
they'll bring it and the Cheesecake
Factory right now our listeners can get
five dollars off their first order of
$15 or more when you download the door -
app and enter promo code
théo th e oh that's five dollars off
your first order when you download the
door - app from the App Store and
interpro mo code Theo
again that's promo code Theo for five
dollars off your first order from door -
I got to tell you that your confidence
is important sometimes one change can
make all the difference you know I've
had times where I had confidence in
times where I didn't have any confidence
well Hair Club knows this and they're
inviting you to become part of the Hair
Club family to see how getting the most
out of your hair can change your life
they understand the emotions you're
feeling and know the questions you have
Hair Club is the leader in total hair
solutions with a legacy of success for
over 40 years it's a long time of uh of
helping people with their hair issues
whether you're looking to revitalize the
growth of your own hair or to learn more
about the latest proven methods for hair
replacement or restoration hair clubs
professionally trained stylist hair
health experts and consultants will
craft a personalized solution to ensure
you feel your best and get the most out
of your hair see for yourself just how
powerful great hair can be go-to hair
club comm slash Theo today for a free
hair health and scalp analysis for new
customers and enjoy a two hundred and
fifty dollar savings on any qualifying
Hair Club service after your initial
consultation you know I know about here
you know I got that bad baby lettuce
hanging off the back
and I'm letting you know that you can
learn all you want and help yourself at
hair club.com slash Theo for a free hair
analysis and scalp analysis enjoy a $250
savings on any qualifying Hair Club
service after your initial consultation
that's hair club.com slash Theo
experience your hair and your life at
its best
only with Hair Club I'm certain that
you'll love the club yeah I was thinking
whenever I was over you guys's podcast
that like nothing ever happened between
me your life you know that right I mean
yeah because I felt like I said that
there and you didn't believe me I did
not not believe you okay yeah and that's
Gianni laughing he thinks things are
funny I believe I don't know what he's
got this energy and I didn't want you I
which is who there was people who
believed that I hadn't seen that video I
I cannot I can't I mean yeah at this
point I can imagine how gullible some
people but like all kinds of people like
oh [ __ ] you see Tom react when he saw
the video then I'm like you didn't get
that that was a joke
yeah like I was like what the [ __ ] is
this and they're like oh he's gonna flip
out he's gonna legit but there's you
know I read an article the other day
there's an estimated eleven hundred
people in hiding in America from y2k
that have no eleven hundred that's how
gullible like it just sang on that
framerate like yeah there's 11 other
people hiding under [ __ ] you know a
Hardee's or hi you know we have no who
think there's nothing up here anymore
like when you think about that level of
gullibility existing yeah yeah yeah it's
it's you can get people to believe
anything it's crazy
yep yeah yeah I always thought the whole
thing was silly with you guys yeah I
don't think that video was weird at all
I didn't think it was weird at all I
mean I thought it was just you know kind
of nice she was kind of taking control
of the interview a little bit and I mean
and that was it I saw that thing like I
don't know years ago I was like and like
what why would I react to that yeah
seem silly did you feel upset that I
didn't try to make any moves on your
wife
no okay I mean I've always thought that
she was an attractive lady yeah I never
yeah there was when when they when you
guys in the green room I was like that
then she was like this somebody was like
what about when oh and you guys were on
TV on the same show or something oh yeah
it's like I mean that was 20 years ago I
don't know like Wow no but even if you
had I'll be like that's 20 years ago
like you can get mad at someone for
something they did 20 years ago yeah
wouldn't be fair be ridiculous
yeah but yeah I never I just want you to
know there was never even you know I've
always thought that she was in a track
like I'm ever seen on TV when I was when
I was you know in college and stuff did
you ever hook up with any of the and
after that on TV into the cast around
the reality show um yeah I'm sure I got
a couple hands yeah think about it was
so long ago yeah eight seven sixteen
years ago now seventeen eighteen years
ago you think was just Handy's back then
I think there was some older given woman
that I kind of had sex with I think one
older woman that I kind of had sex with
yeah that's kind of the story of my life
if you like older ladies no but this is
what a biggest age gap you've ever had
oh I don't know probably um besides when
I came out of my mother probably yeah I
would say I don't know man maybe forty
eight so nine years that's not that
maybe this lady's 48 now and I'm 39
so maybe yeah because at some point it's
almost like you're holding a bag of
someone and they're inside of it that's
what I don't like whenever someone's old
yeah you don't talk about that coming no
but I mean I keep going
next time you hug somebody that's old
uh-huh grip him in the back with both
your hands okay and like and they're
gonna really hold on in this game
they're gonna try to get away a little
and that's nature that's human nature
because they'll feel the grip yeah just
as a human nature when somebody grabs
you from your back you taunt you want to
it's an escape yeah nature right yeah so
you're gonna feel that and you're still
gonna kind of it's almost gonna feel
like you put somebody in a sleeping bag
and
the bag and they try to Ronal and that's
how you feel like sex with older women
is like yeah hey it's kind of rude but
their skin gets kind of loose you know
Johnny you look like you've been with
some old broads what's the oldest youth
oh that's so true isn't it let's get
when I was 16 I hooked up with a 45 year
old woman that is yeah how was it how
was it guys crazy yeah yeah even if
somebody was molested brother yeah that
was it was it great
yeah it was kind of great at the
beginning and then it got kind of weird
towards the end I had a similar thing
kind of weird toward the end in court
that's why I was older than you but I
was still like 20 21 and this lady was
in her 40s Wow and it was not good and
it wasn't good why you fell in love no I
was [ __ ] blackout drunk hmm and the I
mean I've said this before on a pot you
put like when I woke up I woke up you
know he could come out of a blackout and
you're like I don't know where I am
hmm I was looking out a window just
looking into a backyard and I was like I
have like you know when you ever wake up
from a black guy oh yeah I don't know
what I'm looking at right now I was like
it's like flowers for algernon and get
read that book no isn't gonna like that
a little bit yeah I think so thanks good
he's like it's good description they
thread it I just feel a hand I feel a
hand know on my abdomen and I'm like
like I look down like what I mean
because I was that like really really
black bad and then I start you know you
start to have little little pieces of it
come alive yeah yeah and I hear her like
hey sweetie like how are you feeling
like what the [ __ ] and I turn and I'm
not exaggerating I've said this and it's
true it looked like Bill Belichick in a
wig like it looked like a [ __ ] kind
of a smokey a man who smokes and works
at a diner or something
Wow I was like holy [ __ ] and she was
like I'm gonna take a shower and I
thought I would thought she's gonna say
[ __ ] no I thought I was like I'll split
right now like oh and I realize I'm like
picking my clothes up
from all over the house and I'm getting
dressed I realize about to walk out the
door like I don't know where I am and I
also didn't drive here yeah so I just
have to wait in her kitchen for her to
finish shower I'm looking at the fridge
it's got report cards no hits like sixth
grade I was like oh [ __ ] man I'm just
like waiting for her to come down I was
like did you feel sad like do you feel
like I'm trying to wander some of the
feelings that I would probably do you
feel like ashamed yes because it was
like a mom like when she realized that
no I felt I mean I felt a shame because
I can only remember bits and piece I
started to come a little more alive but
there was definitely things I didn't
remember at all you know and like I was
like oh man you know cuz does it feel
good to come out of that and then like
she was so hideous no I was like was she
strong at least it was there what are
some like Regina quality she had a she
had a thick traps like yeah you know she
could she could do shrugs oh yeah but
like no it wasn't a gun yeah I remember
you know what I said big hey do this
hell yeah she could do this I remember
that I was a big fake either like rocks
oh yeah they were rocks I remember I was
going down her name go balls yeah going
down and she remember her grabbing my
face and going you don't want to do that
maybe your ex-husbands ashes were down
there I don't know it could have been a
lot of nasty [ __ ] down there it wasn't
good men that was there maybe she had
something her belly button she don't
want you to see I would have never
thought of that and I liked that way
more way more like how hits ya ya know
you'll ever find it there would you do
that would you do like would you hook up
with like a 60 or 70 year old no no I
have this like I would feel you know
what's interesting to me like it when
you even saying like that moment in the
kitchen where you're sitting there it's
like I would have moments like that and
bike man it's just weird how far we all
go to like get some type of human
connection you know yeah like it's just
crazy links and then I would feel like
there are certain ages where I would
feel like so ecstatic about
this is dip and then later on I would
feel like oh man feel kind of empty
right yes I'd feel kind of empty
which is weird could you kind of shoot
him because you're just people that want
to connect and it's like Yeti go through
all these barriers you know or you know
alcohol and stuff helped kind of keep
the barrier bay but I think ultimately
when you feel that little bit of
emptiness from a from a thing like that
it's a it's a good thing that you feel
it right because it's not it's really
not how you want to be yes sign yeah
it's a good sign that you're not like
you know I felt like that I think on
other like one night okay yeah it is
better when you kind of oh Jesus girls
how someone over - one time he had
probably five six dogs dude in a studio
apartment right yeah and she broke out
that cooter bruh and these animals I
mean it was like it was Thanksgiving
they all jumped up on the bed you know
and I was like this is in you guys love
the animals [ __ ] we tried to we did our
best she doesn't even go like going to
the animal
at first she kind of like put a pillow
like in front of one on Mike
he's still gonna know we're [ __ ] yeah
of course you know like he's Annie could
just put his neck like that like it was
a long animal yeah so I just didn't get
like some of her but it was crazy man it
was almost like being it for like march
of the Penguins a little bit mm-hmm you
know were you [ __ ] up um yeah I'm sure
I've been drinking this is back on you
should drink a little so what did you
like the most when you were party oh
cocaine man did you have a bet like a
top three cities that you would go to
you know I mean like what you would look
forward to you're like that like you
know I mean like when you get a date
you're like [ __ ] Tempe that's where
it's going Oh Tim P was always just a
fun place because it was always a lot of
girls there what was the best coke place
oh I didn't really have I mean New York
LA really really yeah it was just I
didn't do it for a long did it sometimes
up at the Comedy Store and when I would
do it I would get off into these two you
know it almost gave me an excuse to just
get into whatever like I'm her buying a
bunch of coke from a dude that had a
wolf over up near the R
near the 101 and I'm fine he had a wolf
this dude had a [ __ ] wolf not like a
Siberian Husky no I'm talking like Jack
London do like straight off the book you
know and this dude put him in the
backseat bro he gets in the car I just
want some coke his me he gets a call his
mom had died during the yeah
what do you do you have to be there for
them for your coke dealer oh it was so
how long do you stay in the car probably
two and a half hours dude for your like
furniture yeah usually give it to you
for free is you know at the anistar to
pay and everything but it was it was it
was heartbreaking I drove him around for
a while I mean I just felt horrible you
know he didn't have anybody to call it's
almost sad I was like he saw the other
side of like I don't know that was the
worst man dude I've ended up in a lot of
[ __ ] like they they had a guy in high
school who went to the senior prom right
and so he asked me to give him a ride to
like this party after yeah in the car he
starts telling me that he wants to move
to Hollywood right and where are you
this is a high school Louisiana and I
Mandeville Louisiana so he starts
telling me and then he says that people
always said he looks like Damon Wayans
right member named Damon Wayans and he
is like it's a white guy with like a
shaved head it's a white guy yeah he's
like people always say I was like Damon
Wayans and that's why he wants to go to
Hollywood bro and he's like
bawling-crying in my car
yet I'm one of those shirts why is he
bawling crying I don't know he had on
one of those shirts with like other
shoulder pads and I remember like your
mother used to wear sometimes you know
like family it was like feminism but it
was a shirt yes and it was um dude he
had his brow and he was crying the
shoulder pads was a bad bad family crazy
oh I had so many of yeah of course if
your mom didn't of a husband she had a
couple of those back yeah no those were
those were big big dude ladies and he
had that only just literally had to just
be that I had to just like be there for
him I to sit there and listen and just
be supportive you know but and I missed
the whole after-party that's such that's
from your prom yeah Jesus just listen to
him talk about how he looks like Damon
Wayans yeah and what's to me now he's
never
if you want to mr. Hollywood then no I
don't think so I wanted to be an
attorney I think you wanted to be an
attorney yeah
so I wanted to be a doctor you wanted to
be an attorney yeah and I guess looking
back on it I wonder I'm trying to think
if there was I stayed in comedy if I was
thinking about this the other day
because honestly the truth is it
provided me an escape I just didn't want
to settle down I didn't want
I couldn't just be somewhere and I
always you know I could date a couple
you know I could date somebody and then
leave town for a week and then come back
and you could never kind of pick up and
get enough momentum going so everything
kind of started and stopped and you like
that I think I liked it I think it was
the only way I could sir I could be
comfortable what was the turning point
for you
career-wise special no especially do
anything really yeah at all my special
did nothing yeah like it you didn't feel
any change did I remember well first
they had some they had like a group that
started that was like go and bash this
special right like right whenever mine
came out it was like go put you know one
star this time you could still star
stuff on Netflix you may still be able
to and it was like and I started getting
just screenshots of this thread or
whatever that people had made why they
do that I don't know just I mean it was
right around this targeted that's what I
think I mean it was around the time
somebody wrote an article that like oh
this is the Donald Trump of comedy kind
of so there was like just like a lot of
negative stuff you know and and it was
an original that Netflix had done but
everybody else got like a billboard
everybody else got you know put on the
front page like there was just I don't
know they just there was I'm not saying
what was me like obviously it was still
cool to have the experience yeah but it
didn't do anything it didn't like push
the needle anywhere so this did though
this is what it
yeah podcasting and just then just doing
my comedy just you know getting people
out to the show so that you're getting a
lot of return people you're saying like
it's growing from from the live I think
it's growing from a live show yeah yeah
because the net the special didn't do I
remember going to Chattanooga like a
month after the special and I remember
getting there and I was like oh man this
is gonna be yeah my life's changed yeah
right it'll be different
and I got there and there was like seven
tickets sold Wow and it was like and the
owner felt bad I think he even felt bad
a little bit and like I felt bad because
they had you know he paid hot you know
uh a little bit of a premium not much
but a couple thousand bucks you know
like and it was just like man so when
did you start to feel the change like
what how long ago maybe about like nine
months ago that recently wow yeah that's
great
I knew what nine months again people
have been going to the shows and then on
like the internet yeah and the podcast
is doing well it's hard then and once
you start to book once things start
going well to try and I don't know it's
just it's just different it's like like
I always knew myself isn't like an
underdog space yeah and then it's like
you can't you can't not still be an
underdog but it's like it changes once
you have when there's people coming out
and you're getting you know I guess
validation I don't know what are you
getting support yeah yeah it's like I
don't know it's different it's coming I
don't really know who I am in this space
not that I have to but it's just
different yeah yeah you know so it's I
don't know but did you want to tell the
first kind of thing yeah I think dude if
you got into one relation if you got to
know one marriage and you and it didn't
work out then you probably have a lot
more knowledge than you think that's
what I would say no all right you
probably have just such experience now
like you got way more experience than I
do you know what I'm saying dude I
[ __ ] you know I don't have that I
don't have a marriage experience yeah
I've been in you know I've had bad sex
with probably with countless women
hundreds we're about to say hundreds oh
yeah oh yeah dude nobody's provided more
bad sex across America than your boy
right here
really oh I'll put that up against
anybody brah you know what I'm saying
what I think you do do you play the game
do you think you know your number no I
don't you know but you don't want to
even get into it no I don't I mean I
know it's probably a decent number it's
probably something British
couldn't count - let's put it there what
cambro have you seen this little countin
thing
no no it's crazy really you know this
things that kids have with the slide
that's how I was a little bitty with
Pocket abacus
yeah before when he sounds it out and
then one time we ate one of the things
off of it so now I doesn't even know but
the tens really not yeah yeah yeah look
the other day I heard him say carry the
40 and I'm like he's he's done man
mm-hmm
but before we get to another question I
wanted to get you guys a reaction on
this video of a mutual friend of your
guys's Gucci Gucci berry right there
here's Nick right daddy oh wow daddy
long neck and Gronkowski kind of throw
shade on a mom look at him does he he
looks absolutely terrified let's see it
lets see let's play it again
he looks freaked out Wow Gragas [ __ ]
massive dude she's not that massive when
better that neck you're that next guy
something neck is really something but
um are you friends with him what come on
neck yeah yeah yeah second cousins
actually no yeah for real so we're so
that's crazy that that's why I felt like
Gronk you see from down there some shade
at him nope
yes his mother's I guess his
grandmother's sister mm-hmm is from
Mississippi where does he live well like
what area he lives in uh Flint oh that's
right he's gonna come out to my show in
Detroit
he is yeah you know you don't know I
don't know film or something said a
theater he's gonna open the show yeah
what you're gonna have him walk out and
introduce ya and just start the show off
liddie like a titty you know yeah yeah
he loves that Wow the problem is the
problem is havin people have taking
advantage of him two other people took
advantage of him he said uh supreme
maddie or somebody took advantage of him
how did they take advantage of got him
involved you know I'm talking about
supreme Patti si he's a
I mean when I was young it was a lunch
lady who's got like really bad acne and
like just like breaks a bunch of [ __ ]
okay not the human is it human whatever
superhuman no he's like this kid who has
like a really nice house in LA and he
just like oh like he'll run into a store
like break [ __ ] and like walk out like
one of those that's nice
so what a skillset so it's like he took
advantage of longneck
yeah like got him and do videos was
gonna give him some money I got them out
and then worth Gucci Gucci Barry yeah I
don't know I don't know that guy and I
also only really trust him I think he
seems nice but he's always with longneck
though yeah but some of the tattoos on
his face make me feel like I don't know
some of his intentions or I don't know
what they are okay yeah that's me you
don't have a face tattoo I noticed no
yeah do you think it's interesting that
kids are getting this kind of stuff now
like it's almost like our bodies aren't
even like the next step is that it
doesn't matter what you're you know
we'll be wearing like an alternative
layer of skin that's what I feel like
it's a next level well there's also like
people do insert horns beads Jones in
their face the horn thing I've always
been like you want to you want to tell
you one row I know yeah
front horn back horns I mean whatever
you like man that I don't think there's
such thing as it's not gonna matter in
effect how you interact with people no
not at all
yeah it's always gonna be a thing just
like now I mean you know writing [ __ ] on
your face is always gonna have
repercussions yeah yeah but don't don't
it seem like you know when we were young
tattoos you know or when I was in high
school stuff tat if somebody got a
tattoo it's kind of a big deal yeah
right yeah and then it evolves somewhere
you know people are getting these wild
piercings and the stretch jobs yeah and
then now people are even young people
are even getting face tattoos they're
getting actually the most like you can't
dude it's bad but it's getting more
popular would you say oh great any more
popular seems like it's getting more
popular but here's the thing there's no
such thing as it not being an alarming
choice okay the only time it's ever
you're like yeah like who cares it's a
celebrity it's somebody who's like you
know post Malone or yeah dude if you're
[ __ ]
Stadium singing songs go ahead and write
[ __ ] off on your face don't care but
like if you are like a regular dude yeah
you're like I want to work in finance or
something you can't have [ __ ] like
knives and [ __ ] go bucks on your face
she's not gonna it's not gonna work man
yeah do it but like you're [ __ ] shut
up yeah you can't have a tattoo a
[ __ ] of like rant what's that guy's
name Randall Sapp once at Warren Sapp
yeah yeah you can't have warrants that
way I think you're gonna work at that
working well far it's a great choice for
a tat yeah but yeah Oh Famer man but but
to me it makes me think okay well then
we're not using our skin isn't gonna be
like eventually we'll have another layer
that we will wear it'll be it'll be seem
silly it could be like in two
generations when people are all having a
new layer on it like oh can you believe
like I can't believe only gonna be
sealing on nail it someone's crazy if we
run around no ceiling you know yeah and
I think yeah it'll be like oh yeah like
they used to have just their skin
imagine going out every day in just your
skin what a psycho right like I will
seem like crazy people to them I always
think about what people used to smell
like no yeah like a just just even even
a hundred and fifty years ago what did
people smell like you could smell about
the menstrual cycle on someone man oh
for sure but like also you know in a hot
ass day now you you could feasibly be
like I'm gonna shower at [ __ ] three
times today right like back even that
long ago you might not see water to
bathe in four days you know 100 degrees
out and you're wearing tight [ __ ] oh not
like a French [ __ ] you're in a palace
I mean it's just like tight velvet [ __ ]
yeah because and it also took like an
hour someone help you get dressed you're
not taking that off no not while you're
sleeping in that you're getting up
you'll wash your face do you just I mean
your Dookie chute had to stay everything
I bet they let dogs eat cleaner ass oh I
bet ya remember that crotch that crotch
froth on like a Mannion
day-o like Sam Adams down there it's
gonna be nasty yeah man like okay oh
yeah like your [ __ ] dick is pouring a
with someone with the big head on it the
Guiness Guiness yeah yeah like your
dicks born again just for your dicks
point of Guinness Oh from a block away
Oh people would be like who's that
that's Kevin there ya see ya
yeah he's game on the floor huh yeah oh
man magic would smell like in Florida
dude imagine going to visit somebody
writing him letters on your neck whole
months you never show up you [ __ ]
killed yeah all the time that had to
happen and you were just coming to hang
out or imagine if you're like I love
someone oh you're writing letters that's
two months to get there but imagine I'll
be I bet love with so much intense yes
yeah but imagine if you're like alright
I'm aboard this ship I'm gonna set sail
and then meanwhile her letter coming
back like I met somebody
you [ __ ] show up that had to happen
all the time yeah like she showed up you
like took me six months to get here like
I met somebody yeah this is Lois stalker
the slow stalker yeah it had to be crazy
man imagine then going to another
country because a lot of times like
people from different countries do not
smell as appealing to people from other
countries right just because they're not
used to the scent very common imagine
you boat from your country you get off
in you know Pakistan or something yeah
go down you lose your mind you would
definitely lose your mother yeah I'm
getting back on the ship immediately
yeah imagine getting on a ship imagine
when people came to America months dude
you lived on a [ __ ] boat for months
you're probably gonna die for you got
there I had to be out there just
throwing bodies off the back every week
bodies off me back yeah yeah let's get
another question right here this looks
like it's from Louisiana he says he
knows you Tom Tom I know you're thinking
this black guy looks that Steve with
Cincinnati well I opened for you in 2015
and probably the worst comedy club
weekend ever at the Toledo funny bone ah
I'm sure you remember the feature that
ran over was real disrespectful you
heard that he was dating so-and-so I
want you to tell that story because it's
really funny but vo I do want to hear
you're worse comedy club experience keep
up funny fellows Gang Gang Steve Matt oh
man I do remember him I just remembered
him I do remember him was he a bad guy
but yeah but not a bad guy he's a nice
guy was he a bad feature no he will just
talk about somebody else oh he was yeah
yeah
so I remember here's how I remember I
remember that dude was dating a nurse he
married her he married her there you go
remember that he know so what happened
was this actually happened to me twice
at the same club which is absolutely
outrageous mmm the day of the show the
first time mm-hmm
like I see the feature who's booked for
the weekend meeting him for the first
time nice guy there's a guy I got a call
my something having my wife I gotta go
home yeah I gotta leave I can't do the
weekend I was like okay so the club I'm
like oh I have a friend who lives like
an hour from here let's just have him
and they're like oh no we already booked
somebody I'm like this just happened
like how do you have somebody I mean I I
would prefer my friend to come in there
like now as you can't and I guess I
didn't have like I didn't have the juice
all right I didn't make it that wasn't
like calling agents and managers but I
was like I mean I really would prefer
this no yeah it's like okay so then the
guy shows up who they told me is working
and I'm like okay nice to meet you I
kind of heard of him he was nice and
then was a Gary Owen now what's not but
but he goes up there and I'm not kidding
you like at a certain point I forget
let's say like 20 minutes in or
something like how long is he doing and
they're like I don't know I'm like whoa
that's how this works like you need to
know when this he's probably lied him
soon he does 45 minutes no way in the
middle spot and I was like four people
know like these clubs it basically goes
10 MC 20 metal 45
60 headline yeah so the mental actress
did like 45 minutes and he does like a
15 minute merch pitch Oh like when it
starts I'm like all right and then it
continues on like he has bits about it
and then wraps up and mentions it again
I was like Jesus Christ so it becomes
apparent that like he is a big merch guy
mhm and the weekend Josh neat no but he
does have a really good Murphy cuz he
has a good much business that's one
reason I say that it was a super nice
guy and I wouldn't like I don't want to
like write actually but it's not him
right but anyways this guy's whole
weekend becomes about like selling his
merch right he is like they're bringing
in like carts with boxes and I'm like
this is for the middle yeah I'm like
baby rattles TNT you're like what is he
selling and then every show I'm like yo
man like how like once you cut down your
time you wait I don't need you to do 45
does like 31 show I'm like what are you
doing man so it's it becomes this
ridiculous thing and then a couple days
into it you know we're all kind of
talking about it you know staff and
they're like oh it's cuz he dates the
manager I was like okay so that that
that's why she didn't let me uh bring
somebody and I was like alright so no
[ __ ] the next year I show up and they're
like the middle can't make it and I was
like okay and I was like here's what
they're like we already put out an offer
to like six people I'm like what are you
doing
like white wines and them and I already
know that like you know what's going I
know what's happening I go okay I go
layers we're gonna do you already have
your offers out to people that's fine
but whoever you choose can't sell merch
hmm she goes no merch I was like nope
sorry I don't let me guys summer which I
do right I just know that she was like
he's in the merch biz yeah
so I was like yeah whoever it is
cancelled watching and she was like her
head drop
okay her history dropped of the vision
of her children eating that much I not
thought it and then the guy same guy
shows up know what a [ __ ] crazy
coincidence we're in the same clothes is
different say different different
clothes but he was like you know moping
around I heard I can't so he's wearing
like 70 shirts yeah
asking people outside do you want this
and then I [ __ ] go into the lobby and
his merch is in the club's official nose
it's up like what [ __ ] it was one of the
most bizarre experiences where I'm like
why don't you just come out and say what
you want yeah yeah I mean like you just
tell me I'm like I want my boyfriend or
my boyfriend and it's important to him
to sell this or whatever but like when
you pretend like it's not going on you
know like you're gonna beat around I'm
just I'm not gonna help you out with
that you know and so mmm God that made
me mad oh it made me furious and they're
like we could go back I was like yeah
I'll go back I'll go back for a hundred
and ten percent of the door yeah and
half of the bar sales yeah and that's
the offer go ahead and set it up leave
it yeah I'm trying to think of mile I
would but he was great yeah Steve Mac's
kitchen see was it was great to
beautiful kids now I went to while I was
in Louisville and they had and I Dre I
tried to get that if the audience gave
me a hundred dollars right mm-hmm
I was gonna urinate in one of the
speakers on stage right what yeah
however you [ __ ] up I mean I was
having a few cocktails okay so this is
like when you're just part drinking yeah
so we only got to about eighty dollars
right so anyway I got our stage I'm
outside there's some people like saying
hey dude we're going to this we're going
to a house party something you want to
come and I was like only if my boy can
come and I look over and they had an
urban guy you know in like a louis
vuitton kind of jacket mm-hmm I kind of
like a black urban guy okay and so I
said only if my boy can come and I
pointed at him I don't even know this
guy okay and uh and they're like that's
your boy and I'm like yep that's my boy
so next you know we're all in a limo
this guy
happens to be homeless right or not or
doesn't know where his home is right
more that kind of guy so anyway we're
all going to this party and I walked
right over to him as soon as they said
yeah he can come I walked over and I was
like hey dude you ever been in a limo
he's like no I'm like you're coming with
me just no matter what pretend you were
my best friend that's it and was he good
at that bro
so good at it right we get in the car
people that can't take that direction
they don't know what to do he
immediately dude was like oh yeah he
started naming people he actually was a
little too good right he's like oh yeah
you remember our Wallace and nobody
cares like yeah Yvette died you know no
but anyway we get to the party we go in
the house it's like this kind of fancy
party a lot of people there have been
like maybe at a wedding or something and
we're there like four minutes I hear
people scream from upstairs and hear a
window break this guy went into the coat
room stole a bunch of purses jumped out
the window and [ __ ] your boy that's
pretty crazy that's pretty crazy and I
was like man what I did lose changed a
lot did you do the club that like five
guys owned it together you know it was
like I don't remember it's Louisville
downtown that's all I'm a Louisville
improv what I did okay all right no so
that was that was one of Joel's clubs
that they ended up closing there was
another club that these dudes own to get
like friends and one of the dudes was a
recovering addict named his main choice
with crack and he had but he had like a
very addictive
hufflepuff where I was [ __ ] a
sniffing door yeah yeah yeah he was he's
ever have a puff and he was he was
addictive in every sense so he was like
he liked his shirt there's like a blue
shirt I got I got 12 of them yes yeah
okay man so we like we we had eaten
somewhere across the street and we were
like ah they had this really good
dessert there and he was like the next
day he was like I tried it so good I
bought 16 for everybody here I was like
you are out of your [ __ ] mind Hey so
when it comes time to settle he's like
yeah his great week we'd sold out the
shows he's like can you guess what
you're getting and I was like I don't I
don't guess I know exactly what I'm
getting he was like how do you know I
was
we have a deal so since all the shows
were sold out I know the amount of
tickets and I know that take it price
and I know the percentage so then I know
exactly what I'm getting yeah he was
like really I was like yeah dude like
that's how this works
he said oh yeah it goes well write down
what you think like oh I don't think
it's anything I know exactly what it is
so he's like well how much is it Marc
summers Emily was the guy who's caught
up this what are you talking about so he
gives me a pen and paper I write down
the exact amount I go it is exactly this
amount and I showed him he's like that's
not what I have I'm like then you made
him mistake you're wrong and so he's
like I have this and I'm like nope so
then he's like I got it called like
Sandra I'm like okay so in Sandra comes
up and she just like works she's all
coked up probably big blonde hair he's
like his mom said that he's supposed to
get this I have this and she was like oh
and I'm like Sandra listen there's
nothing to debate here it is definitely
this and then she looks at me she's like
mm-hmm he's like I guess you're right I
was like I'm never coming back here
again that's like a venue where like I
immediately took that check I was like
drive me to a bank like right yes
because this is not gonna clear out
Monday dude I did a Ron I did a casino
one time and I felt like I defended
people on stage and they gave me a check
after but I was worried it was over the
weekend that they were going to like
cancel yeah so the whole weekend bro I
ended up staying at the casino an extra
two days and is doing nice stuff around
the building what kind of what city were
you or what area I think Michigan or
something yeah or Minnesota
it's like milling around his doing
nothing you ain't did them yeah I just
think that maybe I didn't do the right
amount of time I literally have been on
stage in like a month I don't know what
had happened and and I got it then I was
like oh I got this and I did not have it
right and it was rough and it was like
their banquet it was like their employee
banquet and it was like I just felt like
I ruined their whole yeah vibe so I stay
I got to move on flight and stayed there
an extra two days and just like was nice
around town and
it's hilarious nice around the building
hug people took pictures and just shook
hands and [ __ ] I did it I did a shitty
like one of the shitty casinos in Vegas
is before I saw any tickets I was
meddling there mm-hmm and I made fun of
one of the dudes and the venue but this
is like a shitty place now like a strip
cuz you know he was like you can go home
like we don't need you for the last show
I was like what
he was like yeah man like we don't we
don't need you to if you're gonna be
like that and I was like this wasn't
like like it was gonna disrupt my week I
was like oh I felt so bad bad that would
hurt my feeling oh definitely her might
and then the headliners set up for me
his dudes I didn't even know he did he
was like he's got to stay he's got to
stay and the guy was like could you not
make fun of the fact that this is a
piece of [ __ ] like yeah okay sorry man
you know cuz I was just doing it I
wasn't doing it to like really rip on
the place yeah yeah like we all know
we're in a shitty place right now
Yeah right like you guys know like
hearing I mean no no I mean you know oh
oh yeah yeah in other words you're like
we're yeah nobody bartending this is not
the Bellagio yes y'all know they're you
know yeah it's bad yeah
well made bad just talking about that
that's crazy man what else we got we got
a your boy right here Nick Diaz has a
question
what up do what up Tom it's your boy
Daniel have your Fitz and your mayor's
on it I gotta ask
I know Tom's new lifestyle probably
doesn't allow much fast food but
McDonald's or Burger King McDonald's my
daughter's is not Donald's gang gang
gang gang bruh it's not even a debate
yeah McDonald's is McDowell's yeah
what is Burger King doing I mean come on
that they've they've really dropped the
ball man do you remember they used to
have the little thing where they had the
pictures of like the handicapped kid
wheels or whatever their characters used
to be like 20 years ago or 30 years oh
these have a picture of a handicapped
kid
yeah the McDonald's kids club and like
all of their group like omegas I said
Burger King oh no this was a burger
Kids Club perfectly like here's radar
you know it was like at all like black
out with like God is there was a classes
there something you know and here was
like here's on wheels and it was like a
handicapped ginger no I remember that oh
you know they used to be their whole
thing it was like this kind of
McDonald's here's color they are and uh
yeah they had the handicapped ginger
right there yeah like Santino in the
chair oh definitely very much those are
the good old days Oh do you like Burger
King you know what I didn't mind their
dessert menu like in the probably early
2000s but I don't like anything they
have now I never liked the whopper yeah
no I mean eat it I mean dude like you
know look if if you have no options
you're gonna you know I mean like
there's certain road trips or you like
we gotta eat event like some point and
you pull off and there's like one place
and sometimes you just settle for
whatever is [ __ ] there right but I
mean if you have options yeah come on
take McDonald's over that [ __ ] every
time you're breaking in that chicken
Asajj suck that the chicken said the
fried one yeah it was good right it was
so good yeah
the traditional chicken say nothing
wasn't yes some of the other choices
they've made have just been extremely
downhill the king that was like scaring
people in their bedrooms and stuff was
there a block is that their ad people
should be funny
thankful because even now the
handicapped ginger the scary can even
now though you managed it I can imagine
what Burger King's marketing budget is
it's gotta be just astron billion
dollars I've been crazy money and you
can't find a [ __ ] advertising company
to get your [ __ ] straight like look at
what some of these companies do with
advertising it's amazing
yeah you know like they should [ __ ]
hire like comedians somebody like really
like a good comic to get involved with
them but this [ __ ] I look at this a
drooling this guy it's a cut it's like
us it's saw five four [ __ ] it's
terrifying then and the burger yeah it's
known that the burger they paint the
stripes on her it's not even at least
just say hey they paint the stripes on
that [ __ ] cooked what grill do you see
it
burger king dude it's two sisters in the
back [ __ ] about the fist what's your
what's your what's your opinion on if
you're taken like the National big-name
burger people five guys what a burger
Shake Shack I in and out where do you
where do you land Oh
Wendy's Wendy's yeah over everybody you
two I go in and out I think it's like a
different yeah I don't know and you're
you're both Wendy's yeah I'm like into
now because I love they have a lot of
Latino employees and that's what and
that's my favorite yeah cuz Latinas
always they're just such a hard-working
group I really like that vibe you know
yeah yeah I think they're gonna in and
out it'll the the training is obviously
superior to every other place by far the
way they treat you to talk to you even
have people like you know sometimes you
go in a fast food place you like you're
a [ __ ] mess your whole life's a mess
you just know it and then in and out
there like you go like what are you
doing there like I'm gonna getting my
engineering degree yeah like like they
just look like they have their [ __ ]
together yeah yeah I agree they do yeah
they're learning we got me reading and
doing the fryer I'll actually ever be
vending yeah yeah it seems like TV shows
yeah but there that's they're they're
primo man yeah I never thought even to
bring Wendy's into the conversation
really Wendy's his next level for me
Wendy's is very unique really Wow yeah
look at burning and yeah the whopper
always looks like it [ __ ] got in a
domestic dispute yeah it does it does
part of the reason I picked that
question because I want to hear if the
McDonald's spot I want to hear your
about your McDonald sponsorship and
whether that was real yeah that was real
yeah yeah so they sponsored us took
money away and then came back and then
made Christina also like a paid in
dorset
yeah that's cool yeah it's very cool so
yeah we're definitely hardcore
McDonald's family now yeah
and why'd they take it away they taken
away cuz um the first episode that they
promoted we had this guy put a butt plug
in his a video we were and he had a
ruined orgasm he came
when he didn't want to cuz he had a butt
plug in and he was [ __ ] a [ __ ] sleeve
and so he was like trying it out and he
was like oh [ __ ] bro outdoorsman you
know what's really crazy the same guy is
on a new Netflix show called like scam
city or something where they it's like a
he's an actor no he's giving it's like a
real show like a like almost like a news
piece show like a like a like a 48-hour
Dateline show where it's called scam
City right and it's like yeah this is Al
he's in the first episode he might even
be in the trailer if you press play on
that Connor would hunt boardman so this
is like cuz I had it shows like
reenactments and then it has real
accounts of what happened in other words
this isn't where he goes oh okay I see
somebody yeah somebody goes uh there's
no trailer when you press play it's just
first first episode well he's in the
first episode he's talking about his
experience in Buenos Aires and so he was
like I was down there and like you know
the guy scammed me that guy a guy did it
who tells that story of his experience
is the guy who put the butt plug in and
had the ruined orgasm his name is Pete
we call him Uncle Terry Danny Brown
calls him butt plug cuz that's him
DPC huh that's him right there on the
right that's him Oh would that be goat
day huh that's the dude he reviews he's
been reviewing sex toys and and he and
he has one where he has a he has a dildo
on a gun Oh God like I'm like huge
machines yeah and he put that in his
that he does wild [ __ ] you know do
people the yeah your ass is kind of like
the last kind of staycation I feel like
like I don't like to kind of yeah I
think if you're putting stuff in your
butt and you're not running across a
border dude then you're [ __ ] yeah
wasting time that's what I said
it's really I don't know man yet you're
put things in your ass no when I was
young I didn't like when I learned about
that I had an [ __ ] yeah but not as an
adult
no no this thing this thing that he puts
in does not seem like JV squad [ __ ] oh
wow dance really advanced in McDonald's
was not cool with it
oh yeah it's like I didn't [ __ ] crab
leg in your sweater you know
and I don't know yeah I got a whole
strand here we got a nice fella right
here hey yo my man this is Tony Segura
coming at you from Oregon Ohio
Conan as Tommy sugar what uh what his
big simplest was you know you two are
one of my favorites so just wanna Gang
Gang
he's a you two are one of my favorite I
respect that yeah indecisive but
confident about it yeah yeah yeah well
yeah an influence hmm I guess like stand
up wise is somebody I think I think it
changes face where you are in your life
mmm you know like as a kid I mean the
first thing I ever saw was Bill Cosby
himself on a special and then I think my
I thought that was really cool but I
think my mind was blown when I saw Eddie
Murphy you know yeah so that special I
was like what the [ __ ] and then I mean I
used to watch used to go in our basement
to watch Def Jam when like Martin
Lawrence hosted it yeah does that felt
like you know like a sneaky
oh you think you're not supposed to be
watching you know like my parents
wouldn't be like yeah put on Def Jam I
was like 12 13 it was crazy yeah it was
so much fun in TV and viewing something
was like a thing something had a sneak
and those before the DVR but you had to
catch it live yeah you know or VCR
record it but you get a hide that tape
and give the tape to your buddy
everything was so much more top secret
that I like me every day and every day
you were like a detective you were like
yeah you were a CIA you were a middleman
all the good crimes are done man
everything now there's like there's
cameras everywhere and there's nothing
to it's even harder to con people like
all that [ __ ] was back when there was
before the digital age man yeah but you
can't even be really good of a criminal
anymore I don't think you can I really
don't think you can I don't I don't
think we're gonna have any and get that
high out of it you just can't even get
that high out who got you have to be
like computer-driven criminal you know I
mean like I logged in I have my hacker I
I broke into this guy's account and
[ __ ] up his world right the crime yeah
and it's not even that great unless
you're doing something crazy unless
you're gonna rush
the jeweler doing this unless you hack
and you you know Bill Clinton's plan you
know apex legends new hack in and
control his yeah his character while
he's doing it you know and he's on
Twitch I get you know it's like how are
you gonna get to any I don't know how
you gonna keep it that interesting mine
would be this guy Jerry Clower if you
can bring up a picture of him ciello wer
and he's out of he was in the southeast
region but he's from Yazoo City
did you know who Killer Bees what
Mississippi I have pretty killer bees
it's two women right no it's not then no
this my guy right here jarick flower Oh
real legend right there too I loved I
was I feel like I was influenced by Rip
Torn who just died oh yeah I loved loved
him loved Rip Torn I loved John Candy
hmm you know as a kid I mean I he was
like just great at all that I only
mention him because he's like a southern
comic I heard about him I thought it was
to whim dominated that region for a long
time did he yes like they don't even
have any southern comedians anymore
really in Hollywood out here and I mean
like on tour I guess Rodney Carrington
would be considered one all right
because he does music and comedy Ron
White but it's been like 25 years since
they've like since they've taken like
rural white comedians or anything like
that I feel like yeah there's not that
many I mean I guess I wouldn't know but
like I only knew about I found out about
killer bees two years ago yeah and
because I was doing a club in Nashville
and they're like oh his son is working
with you and I was like who are you
talking about I had no idea they're like
you don't know who that is
I was like no and they're like he has
been a staple of the south for like 20
years
and like can saw anywhere in that area
hmm yeah they have another guy like that
the ragin Cajun yeah John yes his last
name is I think right now it's just been
so long since I've seen ragin Cajun also
had a hard you know the ragin Cajun
comedian ragin Cajun yeah if you tell
then it'll come up Morgan Morgan yep he
means good east I mean he still is good
I haven't seen him in a bit but man I
mean you talk about inter that I ain't
here
did you ever hear that his wife was a
lottery winner yes that's true right
his wife won the lottery and you cannot
get divorced after that and then he
saved somebody from a burning building
one time Wow
saved a life so what about Robin Harris
to me Robin Harris mmm black woman man a
black man now are oby and I'm thinking
of Robin Harris is on I may be a stern
chef no you're right you spelled it
right I think
yeah that's Robin Harris right there oh
yeah maybe kids remember babies kids yes
so that was his I gotta watch that dude
his crowd work was other level Bar None
huh this dude was a savage you were done
your toes didn't [ __ ] picked you I
gotta watch him then Robin Harris Robin
Harris [ __ ] people up men hilarious the
hilarious most hilarious dude do you
have trouble like do you have trouble
like things keeping you excited and
stuff as your career goes on like a lot
of the excitement of something or you
know is like the journey of it you know
you don't really realize that while
you're going through it yeah is it
different as you find more success and
stuff like that yeah it's a little
different sure and then you start to go
like well I think you start to see like
there's a point when you're like I just
want to be able make a living right and
then you go what truly excites me wait
you know so that becomes more of a
reality I think the further you progress
so you go like what is it that it what's
exciting to me what motivates me what is
it that I want to do I feel like it's
just being creative and involved in
things you know and stand-up it's always
about new jokes right yeah that's the
dadang death feels like just nothing new
that feels like I don't even want to be
here yeah so I know that part of
stand-up excites me just it you know
even a new line is enough to carry me
through a show yeah and that crazy how
the feeling that is that feeling is like
it's that's the feel like it doesn't
even nothing else I don't think about
anything else then then when when you
have like a new tag even you're like ah
get excited to get to that point of the
show to try the tag and so that stuff is
that I mean the other things I don't
know like sometimes I feel like the
whole thing has changed we're like when
you when you start out that's like
people tell you what you want you know
you
being on a TV show I don't know and like
I've been involved in like a bunch of
development deals and I'm like I don't
even know that it excites me to do that
yeah I feel like I'm almost like going
along with right you know I mean like
the way that the tide moves on that I'm
like yeah I guess right you're supposed
to that's right yeah maybe you're
supposed to is it cool is it fun is it
yeah is it worth the time that's the big
one is it your story at all that you're
telling are you gonna have to play a
character that's not even well that you
start to really value time or yeah time
becomes the greatest of all commodity
like you just go man like you know
especially like you have a career this
that's you know developing and moving
along you have a family and you're like
I only have this much time right a in a
year and a week what do you like it's so
important that you put it into something
that you you find rewarding you know I
mean like do you think that a lot of
that do you think that your your
experience and like your achievement is
due to would you if you had a deviate up
a hundred percent right would you say
like what percent is like perseverance
talent opportunity and it doesn't even
have to be those three things but do you
think that it's kind of a mixture of
things do you feel like it's it's a
mixture of things
I mean it's some of it is natural
ability I think everybody has a degree
of ability right yeah in something for
sure yeah yeah but I'm saying let's say
we talk about comedians oh yeah there's
a we we all have a degree of natural
talent right then there's like how much
work you put into it and also like
there's just choices you make choices
that are not even about right some are
about writing the joke and performing
but just make choices like when to do
things when to what - turn down what to
take those are all like choices that you
make it's not like right chance you know
and right deciding to do this with your
podcast is a choice right you know you
you you dictated to do that right and
then things will happen because that so
there's those things some things are
circumstance
um and some picking up people I go then
you got lucky I mean you know I don't
everybody gets lucky a little bit of
everything a little bit yeah you know
but I think it's not that much luck it's
more about putting in work natural
ability making certain choices yeah I
think that's it and it's sticking to it
so many people that like I started out
with you know just people drop out
yeah sure you find that oh yeah somebody
falls in love or somebody just okay yeah
I'll tell me of the conference like to
talk to people whatever happened to this
person that you just go I don't know I
don't know I know you see image shows
and then I just don't see him anymore
you know I heard recently it's almost at
a certain point like the comedy chooses
you in a way that's interesting it's
like at a certain point it's like yeah
this person can live this lifestyle or
can do this yeah I mean I recognize a
little bit like I'll text with daliyah
sometimes like man it's so lonely like
sometimes you're by yourself and you
just had a great show you don't get to
see anybody and mm-hmm you know like you
know like yeah man it's so bizarre
what's your routine like let's say you
go out now you do a big show in Georgia
where the guy said we don't do shows for
some reason crazy I think the video was
also from 1840 that guy sitting in he
said his wife had just left on a
stagecoach his first wife but like you
finished your show what do you do yeah I
guess I usually do I guess I just kind
of go back to the hotel get something to
eat go back to the hotel do you like to
find like the good place in town like
you know I mean are you one of those
people or and I probably should start to
get a little bit more into that part of
me feels like I've been on the road for
so long that it's like it's like you've
done all the national attractions you've
done you know maybe try to find
something that's a little off the map do
you try to stay in the nice hotel
yeah these days I try to stay in a nice
hotel even if it's just to treat myself
yeah you deserve it yeah it's like I've
stayed in I mean I stayed in one place
dude in Rochester outside a lot
Rochester where bro you had to walk
there from the day's end dude it was
only probably about 600 yards but there
was no sidewalk and it was on a busy
highway yeah we've all stayed in these
places this was not there's no sidewalk
yeah there's and if there was a side
well you're almost glad there wasn't cuz
like who will put a sidewalk right next
to this Park
highway crazy streaming there's so many
bad hotels the hotel or the motel where
the door opens just into the you know I
mean to the parking lot
it doesn't feel I stayed in the hotel
motel in Oakland once where our horrible
idea and there's out of the gate man it
was like there were screams going on
yeah just everything was just you got I
feel so unsafe no that's Romano I think
it is labeled basically every mater
every Ramona and then I remember I went
to the counter I'm like what goes on
here what goes on here I asked the lady
at the front desk she goes I don't know
like I gotta get out of here
I feel like yeah probably yeah yeah I
work here but you should leave it was
one night I it was like when I was still
trying to save a ton of money and I
would I went to a Days Inn in Knoxville
and I said look how to pay you a couple
of hours to sleep on this the floor of a
room right and the lady's like yeah
that's fine you know but my boyfriend's
you have to sit in there while you sleep
it was so crazy
and he did yeah and I paid him like 40
bucks and stuff in there for like three
hours he just looked at you I don't know
what he did I hope he dozed off you know
I like to hope that he dozed off she had
she set a monitor to watch you sleep I
think she was nervous about it but she
wanted to be helpful you know yeah
that's the thing these days it's like
you can still be helpful but everybody
there's like a level of like risk and
uncertainty that comes with everybody
yeah yeah what's true what motivates you
what makes you want to do more it's
funny even hear you say that like a new
line or a new joke yeah you know we're
talking about a new experience like my
legs fell asleep in an uber the other
day and I had to get out in this black
or was driving and she was pissed that I
wouldn't get out and I'm like how did
your legs fall asleep I bad circulation
really I mean my legs yeah in my arms I
can do almost anything but so it's like
the next thing you know it's like I got
to get out right and she's like I
already accepted another passenger you
know and it's like my legs are asleep
she's like we use it for human being
this ever said this to me no I literally
she's like if she goes if you knew
you're gonna be handicapped you should
have brought a wheelchair and I'm like
this is it's almost at that point unsafe
er to be in with this girl what do I do
[ __ ]
just jumped out like hands first like a
[ __ ] and then pulled yourself yeah
like I mean yes scooted your scoot like
I'm out of [ __ ] [ __ ] and then how
long did you say on the sidewalk with
your unluck I'll be two minutes actually
Robbie a little longer cuz I got on my
phone okay and I don't even realize it
my legs it kind of woke him back up but
yeah a frequent thing that happens I
would say it happens to me if I'm doing
like a stool or something going number
two or if I am but that's where it's
coming but you're also were just sitting
in a car yeah
but this lady I think the seat was uh I
would say was aftermarket mmm-hmm I can
head hey yeah just cut off the
circulation it could have been part of
her mood you never know okay I'm out
there it's on it's an unlit area you
know couple of [ __ ] pop you know
poppers pop out the trunk and get you
you know not a bad move really yeah you
got the crossbar within the seat that
cuts off people's circulation they get
out can't walk right to guys get them
standard yeah yeah that's called the
Cincinnati [ __ ] shuffle huh ask
everybody knows oh I'm sure Gary knows
do it if you would ever answer my calls
any other questions that we have met
just two quick patreon questions before
we get out of here Mike new she asks
what are some things that make you
irrationally mad for me it's too loud
chewing noises so Tom what makes you
rationally mad hmm rationally mad it's a
good question
olives you hate it [ __ ] hate olives
Oh huh oh all boil all olives all olives
yes but olive oil is fine but an olive
can [ __ ] itself I don't at all don't
like raspberry like flavoring mm-hmm
like a raspberries fine yeah oh yeah
raspberry drizzle oh it's [ __ ]
disgusting that's good I wouldn't be
friends with anybody that's into it yeah
that's how much it upsets me anyways
just sneaking around having some yeah
yeah Jeremiah Watkins eats that [ __ ] out
there but see I don't like him one of
his parents yeah one of his parents was
a UH did I think cake deco or something
yeah so he's none of those pipe and
he'll of his pipe that [ __ ] right into
his mouth
I mean the look the loud chewing yeah or
anyone who's like
really clearing their throat a lot yeah
you know public were you like come on
man are you doing guys doing with their
teeth oh yeah I was in a steam room you
know this guy was like I was like you
get it did you get it
dude I was in a self-esteem room and it
was bunch of people just trying to feel
better
yeah um I think one of mine this is
funny I thought about it one of mine is
um like I walk in a bathroom and I can't
help but smell in the air someone's
pooped in there recently mm-hmm and it
bothers you if someone does that always
make us bothers me that I can't go in
and not check I got you yeah yeah yeah
like even if I don't want to check I'll
walk in like I'm not gonna
I'm the breathe naturally in there but
I'm not gonna breathe smell if someone
has been killed you and it do it I I
sometimes walk into a bath and I check
myself I go I got [ __ ] man I get like
upset at how much it smells like [ __ ] oh
yeah and I'm like where do you want this
[ __ ] you're in the bathroom like they're
supposed to [ __ ] here yeah I'm still mad
at the level of [ __ ] you know I can air
hey [ __ ] who's coming here yeah
they're all like there's a bathroom
are you [ __ ] like yeah but come on man
yeah check your diet bro this is
terrible let's get upset yeah I wonder
if there's like certain bathrooms
because like certain people come from
certain parts of the country where
there's more of a thoroughfare every
International Terminal yeah you start
mixing different cultures of different
shits in there and you're like one of
the big ones holy cow well we dr. drew
say about that that's what I want to
know I'll ask him definitely ask him
and also when rich people don't let
their dogs fight each other that [ __ ]
[ __ ] gets on my nerves
yeah you know there's some rich people
like I love an apartment but there's
some rich people that walk their dogs
around me and I can hear the the people
will argue but not let the dogs fight
you know all right you want to be able
to scrap a little bit the dogs want to
fight I'll tell you what makes me the
most didn't know you said it makes me
the most upset I [ __ ] hate people
like this yeah anybody with money that
drives a sensible car yeah I want to
[ __ ] absolutely
out in front of their family I hate that
[ __ ] like how sensible like what are you
like a guy with ten million dollars it
was like I love this Prius like but yeah
no you don't know you don't yeah you're
you were raised here you live in this
world you know your options and you're
gonna go for like the sensible well it
gets great mileage is that really your
concern okay and it gets great mileage
or do you wanna have fun when you're on
the road yeah it'll be a little I
[ __ ] hate it dude men that wear bike
helmets bro
yeah that wear a bike any sort of safety
helmet dude yeah I'd rather be at my
dad's funeral 200 times then see you
then at one see my dad come home safely
to dinner with a [ __ ] ailment and an
elbow pad oh I hit my elbows or my knees
dude yeah I'd rather see my dad beat my
mother didn't come home with an
unbruised spouse yeah with [ __ ] elbow
pads I was the worst I agree that [ __ ]
makes me mad bro anything that's like
real wimpy [ __ ] yeah you know like they
used to have this by asking on the back
of the bike and you would sit on there
and my mom used to carry us she would
ride the bike and [ __ ] carrots with
her other arm and going bike rides like
it was just all you play sports chill no
not that much do but I fell off the
swing set one time so [ __ ] hard that
I was a legend bro you know I'm saying
like I pretty much got all the trophies
long up Oh swung up as high as you could
go swings are [ __ ] fun man now that I
have kids yeah we have a big-ass swing
set in the back pretty cool the best you
forget how much fun that was it's such
an easy way to have a blast yeah and
then you really start kicking and you're
like yeah up and that one time you start
to let your legs out a little bit and
then you [ __ ] it up and land on your
back it's sighs ah yeah but it is still
fun it's fun yeah it is fun it's like
before they're like you even heard of
like bungees that's the the precursor to
bungy jumping and [ __ ] yeah I was like
swinging parallel to the [ __ ] ground
that was like first second grade and you
learned about those toys aren't getting
out of first grade they had swings but
kindergarten playground didn't have them
I know and it was like whoa you can
remember you see a swing a slide that
turns for the first time because there's
slides like slides are great and then
you see it turn and you're like yeah
this [ __ ] goes in a loop it's like
realizing you can date sisters you know
you're liking
I can't yeah this thing's got a little
twist to it anything else guys you want
to hit with Tommy sugar right here we
got one more good patreon question then
we can get him out of here this comes
from Tom Fredrik
he says Tom you have maybe three and a
half years before you die who do you
want out of these four choices to raise
your kids with Christina Chris D'Elia
Theo von
Bobby Lee Andrew Santino zero really you
[ __ ] guys you gotta your mind don't
include me with that pack of wait is
Chris okay
who else Andrew Santino Bobby Lee and
Theo okay well you and Bobby are
immediately off the list okay I'm up all
day then so I would like the debate
though it was two guys that debate is
between Santino and alia so let me see I
mean daliyah's got more money yeah be
able to you want to love the kid though
right but here's the thing
I mean I gotta think about their future
their education what what about if
somebody's actually to care about him
that's the thing that he was he actually
was very sweet when uh like he when we
when we were when like a year ago when
when his doesn't make a dent sweater tip
[ __ ] $2000 in quantity sales in one
day problem yeah he no he bought very
nice thoughtful gifts for the kids and I
was thinking about kids I was like this
is very thoughtful
he was like yeah just you know Congrats
I was like you know for this ridiculous
hypothetical that would play into it
Santino I know wants kids I mean incan
problem I'll give you I'll give you what
one up over Bobby
okay that's obviously like I would
choose Bobby Bobby the [ __ ] if I want
more veteran that didn't even serve yeah
I mean that's an immediate like needle
in the arm
oh I'll draw Bobby to VFW's around
America and watch him get his ass beat
let's not give up too
so Bobby's last
argued Mohammed okay and then I think
Santino he's but he's - I think he's a
little bit of a unpredictable yes
you know unpredictable father that's
gonna be his yeah and that tempers gotta
be you know I don't want them seeing
that every day
Oh punching holes in walls and [ __ ] and
every time I see his wife I kind of look
at her like you're right yeah yeah yeah
everybody knows you know stuff some gall
it's a lot of eye makeup you know so far
easy huh yeah I was going to an event
tonight or something yeah no just new
shadow came in and I just figured
painted on like extra thick for today
Wow black face on for a night out at
dinner yeah just something different
yeah yeah so it's a Santino second place
yeah yeah so Wow
I guess Chris unbelievable yeah sorry
man it's okay I mean I'm just like Bobby
why don't you just [ __ ] but that's so
easy bro that's like beating a [ __ ]
Bobby is a throw pillow but that
occasionally does things okay there's no
difference bro yeah bro check him for
bone nothing bro spent 40 minutes
feeling his body for any sort of boner
infrastructure yes he's such he's so
funny and such a bizarre dude yeah so
bizarre he might be the most bizarre
when I really think about it and it
might be you know what cuz you're both
you're kind of like this to where
sometimes I'm like the [ __ ] is this
person saying you know like I'm like are
you doing a bit or are you being serious
like you have a little bit of that yeah
he has it to a degree where I'm like is
this really you and then and then I
sometimes walk away being like no like I
think that guy's really like that yeah
where it's like you you're this close to
being institutionalized bro
oh yeah with Bobby oh he's got autism
dude he's got that jaundice autism that
G autism they call it he's you
he's got that freak oh that guy oh bro
you feel me Dawg you got that [ __ ]
that wild Saul sent him you gonna
[ __ ] work on the Spanish or what I am
did I would they would bake my life man
yeah cuz my father grew up down there at
doing his whole family's missionaries
down there in the Quran WA mm-hmm and so
it would be cool to go down there and do
even just like do some fundraising tours
or anything even if we just did three
dates or something you know for me it'll
be probably about four or five years
till I'm you know can speak applica
bleah
so start yes dark yeah watch shows watch
shows in Spanish you watch narcos I'll
be there yeah I'll watch that whole
series man it's all in Spanish oh if one
of the shows is in Colombia dog be
awesome if I can have my phone Hetalia
Pablo no we can do it yeah great little
Tony's oh yeah thank you so much Tom
sugar for being here yeah there's a lot
of fun that's on the new space looks
great
well thanks for the inspiration man I
mean you guys have uh you know you guys
are whenever I got to your studio the
other day I was like wow this is a vibe
in there survived yeah this is one - man
this is really cool cool like this
thanks man Jionni the twink pink that
pic guy says yeah player is that you
made this goddamn yeah he plays
intramural spar wait where are you guys
from by the way I'm from La Crosse
Wisconsin okay and I live to eight years
in Minneapolis - okay you from Rhode
Island
mm-hmm and Jionni is an actor and Nick
is a well the best podcast producers I
think that's dice man Congrats
amongst other things they do other stuff
Nick plays basketball across the street
sometimes where did you live in
Minneapolis uh all over I mean mostly
mostly by campus I went to University of
Minnesota okay and then ya work to acne
for a couple years you did really don't
even know that yeah yeah Wow when you
guys did your whole tour in China it was
like big news attacked me and stuff that
was the year I worked there you were
there and attack me well yeah
oh that's cool man I love Louis yeah
yeah I've never been that Club what
hands down best I mean it's it's it's
either one or two depending on who you
ask if they've played it who is one of
the cruel you most unique people that
ever came out
see you perform or somebody that shocked
you that that was like at the show or
something yeah mmm trying to think been
trying to think about going to I don't
have an answer really but it tastes
never come to going to your shows Tyson
came to my show in Pittsburgh yeah
Wow that was good that was pretty wild
I'm Tyson Chandler now is weird I mean
to be like hanging out with Mike Tyson
in the grove Mike Tyson oh yeah why I
like it have them just like hang out
smoke cigarettes and you're green like
an up green room smaller than that room
and you're just like what's up and like
how many white dudes would it take to
jump Mike Tyson now at his age right now
yeah depending on the type of dude what
about you and me oh no we had that we
would be dead I would be do it I
wouldn't do it no I think if there was
like maybe eight eight people maybe but
also you know that like he's gonna get
he's gonna throw like three haymakers
that take out two people each and some
two dudes are never gonna be the same oh
yeah
special type of brain damage yeah yeah
from that guy he could still I saw him
you know he like showed up at a gym he's
not in the same shape obviously and and
he was like yeah yeah he was just like
if he was throwing our hooks on a bag
and oh like that right there that hook
he just threw mm-hmm oh my god you'd
help that would devastate you in ways
that look at that [ __ ] yo my name I have
a bad neck too oh well yeah I mean it
would just be permanently bad man oh you
think it would feel good kind of getting
hit that hard a little you wouldn't
remember it and so maybe like do you
remember what life was like before that
hit had that kind of thing but yeah it
would [ __ ] you up so badly man I
remember Willie D was at a show I did in
Houston you know from the ghetto boys
hmm
that was like a number of years ago I
think that was cool though it was cool
to know he was there and yeah he left I
was like that's cool yeah I mean just
didn't there like yeah he was here me
definitely laughing laughs yeah so you
don't know whether he liked it or not
Gloria Estefan went one of my shows one
time really where and left this is in my
me mmm he's probably bought 10 years ago
it wasn't that like a fun coke place
when you were heavy into coke yeah I
think everybody's idea of me having a
coke was basically me behind coke up at
the Comedy Store and just doing it back
at my apartment like there wasn't it I
didn't have like fun times where I was
like in Cuba sitting on a beach sad yes
doing coke it was like Doug Stanhope
without the girl with the blue hair you
know yeah a little side apple you know
they can go yeah bingo
it was beautiful too and so was Doug but
it would be like yeah it was just
somebody by themselves just doing coke
yeah just touching a soft wiener just
looking at you know escorts on the
internet negotiating with escorts
pricing them down I mean I priced like
10 or 12 dollars that I mean it got to
the point would be eight how are you
having them a lot no no never was having
I'm just never had just like trying to
work out do yeah yeah sorry yeah it was
basically that's your Latin influence
man that's that's what that is
yeah it's like the [ __ ] sloth of ball
Street basically I was like shitty
animal like I just don't want to be
taken advantage yeah that was it I don't
want to spend you know 325 seems crazy
you know it's 7:00 a.m. I'm a handsome
guy though doesn't not thing like yeah
how about cut me some slack I'm a
handsome guy you tell them that it's
just like a you send him a picture to
verify them no no I would stand up I'll
do that little sketch thing once that
thing came out of the phone where you
can get somebody who I look like that's
cool last question yeah do you still
masturbating me ever as an adult after
you get married and stuff like that are
you out of your mind of course yeah yeah
all the time
you don't jerk off oh I jerk off I
jerked off probably more recently you
would imagine but I'm just wondering do
people still do it when they get mayor
100% yeah do you feel bad when you do it
like I'm keeping this from them no no no
no I think it's just part of like
regulating your body yeah of course
sometimes you know I found like I know
somebody who jerks off like before shows
I'm like for me that's like a knockout
punch it's like the only ckf
well that's during the show like I feel
like before the show I want as much
energy as possible right yeah I like the
free show
work out I like to go to the gym if the
shows at 7:00 I'm in that gym hotel gym
at like 5:00 yes so I feel alive and I
want to do my show like that jerk off
and go to a show no that's insane
now after the show that's great jerk-off
time yeah yeah back in the hook like
when you really want ya do you sleep in
that bad habit that jerk-off then really
yeah remember dude number all the times
yeah I think it is it's the bad at yeah
jerking off late at night is been
looking at pornography okay bad habit if
you do it all the time yeah yeah I don't
like jerking off I don't like seeing
myself I jackal ate that much and you
don't know I used to not mind in a noose
like watching it I wouldn't watch a
whole all of it but I'll watch like
right in the beginning yeah you know you
shoot big loads do you shoot ropes like
what do you got well a small quantity
you know like a dribbler are you I know
[ __ ] Pete Maravich let's line up if
we stood at the [ __ ] end of this
table uh-huh I'm backed up even a couple
of days I'm I mean I'm getting distance
on this thing no you're not yes I am yes
I am wow that's incredible yeah I mean
also like you know how you get you have
like pumps right like an orgasm is like
it's like you're your dick go like don't
yeah right how made you go through you
think like count them out in your head
six seven eight maybe yeah the last two
are weak weak weak then you got to be in
my body to feel them yeah exactly
yeah I'm like on a bad day twelve
thirteen on a really strong day I'm up
to like sixteen yeah oh my god I went to
a doctor about it that's crazy
you know he told me what you're lucky
yeah that's crazy I mean I bossed him
too I bus probably you know good pretty
good nuts but I don't do
I don't think I'm you know I'm gonna win
anything no I'm winning I'm winning
championships yeah I could get Peter
North a run for his money I could yeah
it's good stuff I could give Mae West
and run for a my own that small ones Tom
Segura thanks for being here thank you
for having me yep Tom gate begins guys
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let my mama
[Music]